foreign
[Music]
hey yo what's up another episode of
congratulations you know uh uh before we
even do the intro thing that we always
do which is just great it's great to do
the intro thing we love the intro we
love the song made by Mr Green and we
love all that just wanted to thank you
for being here man very grateful we love
we love having you if you're part of
this cult because this isn't a podcast
it's a cult and you know that and we
love that
um and we are going to be you know
building a log cabin at some point and
sharing ideas in the tall grass so I
just appreciate you you know if you're
part of this channel like And subscribe
it's great and if not dude if you're
just a casual listener you're not part
of the cult that's all good too my baby
uh but this is another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
did I drink too much coffee today yes I
did I did okay full full Bonkers just
got it going on just drank a bunch of
coffee
am I coming down yes that's how I feel
like it's happening I'm coming down it's
like uh
it's like that fast relief release
coffee uh and I'm just like CH you know
what I mean I feel to come down and I'm
just chilling because caffeine was not a
whole part of my thing in December and
really January and I'm like you know I'm
taking a little bit of a baby sips now
I'm getting back involved with the
caffeine and and we're we're playing
with it you know we're dancing we're
letting the caffeine we're taking a sip
we'll let the caffeine dance in my mouth
right and uh and we're seeing you know
this is my second or third I don't
remember honestly
[Music]
but uh is dancing around my mouth having
a good time on my tongue uh and that's
absolutely disgusting if you think about
it if I said that in front of my wife
she would go ill but she's not here in
this room she could definitely hear me
outside probably and she probably go in
like this ill but whatever it doesn't
matter
um I'm happy you're here and this is yet
another episode dude we just keep on
having episodes huh that's it it's not
like a TV show that ends eventually I
guess I'm just gonna keep doing this
podcast forever or what is it dude you
know
I don't know I guess I like doing it I
like doing it and you know it's it's fun
it's a fun thing to do I do too many
podcasts of course because I'm also on
Golden Arrow I'm also on lifeline and
I'm on this one too and it's just too
many
but I just like doing it you know
and uh I love doing stand up too I'll be
in new uh well actually this will
probably come out after that
I'll be in Kansas City I'll be in Tulsa
Springfield I will be in Minneapolis and
I will be in Austin Texas Minneapolis
crystalia.com go to get tickets don't
push me uh and I'm gonna be in Midland
wherever the [__] that is don't know
where Midland is but it's in the middle
of the land of Texas apparently probably
uh it's in Texas and it's called Midland
so that's it
um yeah man it's been a great week uh
you know I guess it's been a great week
and you know there's always ups and
downs and we're just uh we do what we do
my baby let me add it up
um
and uh my son just got done with his nap
you know what's really beautiful is my
son
uh got
um he has Robot it's his birthday coming
up so he got robot tattoo he wants to do
a robot theme party
and you know Kristen is Crafty and she's
doing all the things like she made a cut
out she made a whole time machine and
like a rocket ship and like she's in
she's an insane person in a beautiful
way she just gets like she she does a
lot of stop-motion animation you know
she used to do a lot of it and now she
just kind of like does everything for
Calvin and it's beautiful
and it's beautiful and she's just like
got this machine that prints out robot
images and just cutting them out with an
X-Acto blade and all that and just it's
crazy
and uh he's got tattoos of robots on his
where do you want to put it he wanted to
put it here and here because he wanted
to be like dada
and that was just beautiful
and I love being a dad and it was
beautiful and another thing that he did
was beautiful that I now he does this
thing where he wants to lay in bed he
wants he says we left me for a little
bit whether it's me or
or Kristen or both of us we lay with me
in bed for a little bit either we both
do or she does or I do whoever's putting
him down
and we say yeah and now it's becoming
like a thing we lay with me for a little
bit so I laid with him for a little bit
I was putting him back because Kristen
was already in bed she goes to bed a
little bit earlier not because she's
eight months pregnant but
I put him in bed you know Calvin's like
he's on comic time dude he stays late he
stays a wiggly whatever so could lay in
bed for a little bit so I laid in bed
for a little bit and then I left I gave
him a kiss and good night buddy and I
walked away and as I was walking out the
door he said Daddy I said yeah he said I
have a little problem I said what what's
that buddy and he says I need a kiss
and I go you
got it dude and I went over and I said
where and he said on my cheek and I
kissed him on the cheek and I went uh
and I want you know and I just uh and I
went to bed dude it's the whole thing is
just like
they say what's the meaning of life and
I go like this
raising your kids
um
but then I know it's like some people
have kids and they don't want anything
to do with it and that's really what
that makes me sad so uh but you know
that's not what this podcast is about we
don't talk about sad things we talk
about happy things
um yeah we talk about happy things
what's with everything getting shot down
out of the sky
what's going on there huh
what is it about I know it's part of it
is the media it just I have trouble
believing and look I do believe Joe
Biden is a lizard and goes into the
ocean and sheds his skin
but
what is the deal because look I told you
you know what letter to the alphabet I
support and I you know I'm not saying it
because I don't want to get demonetized
and flagged but you know what letter it
is it's a circle with a line through it
that's me dude
um what's the deal with all of a sudden
now everything's getting shot down out
of the sky remember the Chinese balloon
that got shot up they left first of all
they left it up in the air about where
was it above it was above I can't even
remember somewhere in America they left
it this is how much has happened things
have gotten shot out of the sky since
then
I don't remember where the first one was
the first one that they reported on they
left it up in the sky above America for
like day for like weeks
so I'm like well okay
but then all of a sudden they shot it
down
because people were like what's the deal
with this balloon we don't know what's
going on
where's it from and then somebody's like
it's a Chinese thing
we don't really know and then they're
like okay we'll shoot it down and then
Biden was like
ah oh and then shot it down Weeks Later
so it's like
shoot it down way earlier if you're
gonna shoot it down shoot it down
immediately
know what we can't have balloons from
China be doing
Gathering Intel
so if you decide you're gonna shoot it
down shoot it down immediately before it
can gather Intel
whoops it's got the Intel
spin up for also things like technology
can gather Intel immediately so shoot it
down very quickly I'm talking about
get it going
once you see a balloon
shoot it as a matter of fact we're
living in a world where if you see a
birthday balloon shoot it down because
it's just like we can't be having
Intel
be gathering
our Intel is for us
after a Chinese five balloon was shot
down February 4th at least three
unidentified objects have been shot down
over North America
okay so this is what this means
many things have been hovering above
America for a long time and now it's a
thing
so here's what I gotta say
I guess doesn't matter
they already got the Intel
shoot down whatever you want
done mad at this point
the US military shot down at least three
unidentified flying objects over the
weekend after a Chinese spy balloon that
had invaded American ears anything that
invades American airspace shoot it down
yeah
right
there's no people in it cap it
there's no people in it let my cat talk
to it
what up homie
at this point it's unclear what the
objects were their purpose or who sent
them if it's unclear what the objects
are they're bad
right
nobody looks at a pizza box being
delivered and goes huh because you know
there's a pizza in the Box
if you see that smiley Amazon thing
you're fine it's some towels or like
some bulk nail polish
if you see a box with a bunch of Chinese
writing it
[__] being delivered in Rochester New
York
your interest is picked you go hey the
hell is that
what is clear is that the United States
of Canada have become hyper Vigilant
since the balloon incursion and that
yeah okay so February 4th the Chinese
spy balloon is shot down over the
Atlantic Ocean k
should have done it sooner whatever an
F-22 fighter jet fired a Sidewinder
air-to-air missile to the balloon okay
it was sixty thousand sixty five
thousand feet which is double the height
of an actual commercial airline
why do I know that because I'm smart
because I fly a lot I know that 30 000
feet is the that's where the air is thin
and you can kind of whatever so if it's
60 000 feet the Chinese people be going
way up there
um okay so that's fine February 10th
this is six days after the Chinese a UFO
a UFO is shot down off Alaska
on Friday a U.S fighter jet brought down
an unidentified object over the Waters
of Alaska the object broke into pieces
after being shot down it was most likely
not a balloon
okay well then what the what was it a
drone
why is it stationary okay so it's a
balloon gather and end out
the a defense department official said a
White House official said the object was
the size of a small car that's too big
all right so whatever
it was headed toward the North Pole
before maybe Santa was doing some
surveillance
oh oh no that's what he did when I got
shut down so then the next day dude a
UFO is shot down over Canada
another F-22 fighter downed another
object on Saturday over the Yukon
territory which is Alaska
right yeah uh I know that because I'm
smart
okay so then there we go so then unclear
what the object was but prime minister
Justin Trudeau Canada said Canadian
airspace okay
then the next day oh you have so shut
down UFO how do I keep saying UFO a UF
oh a shutdown over Lake Huron which is
in Michigan area whatever Montana oh
first appeared over Montana and then it
wound up in Michigan hey dude don't let
these weather balloons or these Intel
Gathering balloons be traveling
they're getting all sorts of Intel you
want to get an incel over Lake Huron not
a big deal what are you going to get
some waves maybe you're going to get
some people from Detroit on vacation
okay
but you let it be traveling
so February 13th they say the objects
were not sending signals but did pose a
threat okay
what the third look the first part I
don't care
if it's not sending signals or sending
signals it doesn't matter
as long as it poses a threat
hey if it's pose in this threat
it doesn't matter let me say it clearly
if it's posing a threat
it doesn't matter if it's sending
signals or not
get it
right
so then the guy the White House is
saying
hey guys
one thing's for sure and we just want to
let you know
it's not aliens
so okay they keep going on and being
like so it's not aliens all right so
number one
that quells my fear on it not being
extraterrestrial
but then also you know what's definitely
evil humans gather an Intel that aren't
American on our soil but also what it
means more than that is
it's aliens
because
that's what you say when it's aliens I
don't want everyone getting you know
what it is not it's not aliens oh
oh
I was lying now you're this tall because
they shrink you
the alien shrunk you
I just like what's the if you're not
just all of a sudden shooting down four
balloons
in 10 days and it hasn't been happening
right
so what's the deal but here's the thing
the media is not going to tell us but
here's the thing nobody's going to tell
us so here's the thing you can't even do
your own research because we don't know
so the media read it nobody knows so I
guess the government is just gonna be
doing what it does and also I mean the
Chinese government and also I mean the
American government
so it's just gonna be doing what it's
doing and we're just going to be sitting
so you know the people were like I gotta
get to the bottom of this we need to do
our own research we're [__] anyway
dude
this all goes back to the thing where
it's like you can't take our guns we
need our guns because what if the
government overthrows and the thing and
that and this and that oh what are you
gonna stop with your measly little AK
what are you gonna stop with your have
your go I am not against guns
right to bear arms okay cool sounds good
I don't give a [__] but here's the deal
though
somebody
wants to come get you
they can mow your house over with a tank
so
great so great
but all good I don't know man we're all
[__] I guess I start thinking about
things like how it's like you know when
you think of stuff like chat CBT
you know in the technology it's just
exponential and technology is just I
know it's been a while it's just getting
started dude
exponential exponential we're going
double it we're going to double it we're
going to keep doubling it until the
until they kill me almost but that's
fine but let me look at the up to you
the YouTube almost opened my mouth but
let me look up in the YouTube dude see
that's me in this podcast I let you guys
understand the real me I doublet and a
doublet and I almost rip up my mouth let
me let me see if I can pull up this
Tupac quote double it until
they kill me Tupac
um
of course the music's come up interview
is this it
is it
we love a Tupac interview
well play well absolutely play please
well play please oh this whole thing is
like 30 minutes long great
that means with a Big Slice okay
so good I need to dress like that I'm
not even [__] around dude dude we're
a a what do you call it a a leather
vest
and a beanie
and nothing under the leather vest
is just the absolute illest outfit and I
gotta start doing it dude this is a test
remember when they do that
I gotta start doing it
and I will frankly I got beanies already
I got beanies I bought them already I
bought some Carhartt beanies here I'm
putting this video on this thing so you
can have it Tupac
it's right there
um
I got beanies from Carhartt that's it
dude that's fine I got them I got a
bunch of different colors you know how I
do it when I get one thing I got all the
different colors and I'm gonna wear them
you know and that's how I'm gonna be and
I don't want any Kickback dude uh
because every time I wear something
someone's like dude you
I swear to God I could put on a T-shirt
with a cat on it you know a year ago you
would have said if you wore a t-shirt
with the cat on it you would have flamed
them
if you're not growing you're dying
that's what I say baby
um
but yeah dude stop shooting stuff down
off the sky is what I'm saying but what
was I saying about doubling it until
like keep doubling it until it kill me I
don't remember
hey guys let's take a break from the
show I want to talk to you about ship
station uh listen it's great first of
all it's great that's me crystallia
saying it in a landscape we're free and
fast shipping is the norm it can be hard
for smaller e-commerce businesses to
compete keep yourself competitive with
ship station when you use ship station
you can lower shipping costs make
returns easy and keep your customers
happy and that's the name of the game
with all the time you save from uh
automating uh automating your shipping
tasks you can keep your business growing
all year long running merch for me uh it
can be stressful obviously it's it's a
whole big deal having ship station uh in
our Corner makes several aspects of that
a whole lot easier
um I love ship station uh it just makes
it easy to grow your business by handing
uh they handle your orders um from every
platform in one place shipstation
effortlessly integrates everywhere you
sell online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and all of those more than that
uh with Enterprise solutions that make
Warehouse optimization easy ship station
scales uh
when you do with the best discounts in
the industry the best discounts in the
industry you'll never worry about
overpaying for shipping get up to 84 off
USPS and UPS rates that's 84 84 percent
uh and if that's not enough use my promo
code to try shipstation for free for two
months
over 130 000 companies have grown their
eCommerce businesses with ship station
uh that's a lot and 98 of companies that
stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life so you do the
math keep growing your business all year
long with ship station use promo code
congrats today at shipstation.com to
sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's shipstation.com promo code
congrats thanks
crazy crazy
but uh I wanted to uh I wanted to talk
about the uh dude you know what's crazy
is this um what do you call it the uh
The Flash movie splitting everybody dude
flash comes up DC all this stuff
happened with Ezra Miller right
alleged I have no idea but you know they
arrested him for kidnapping and grooming
and you know
uh uh uh abuse and and and uh burglary
and like everything [__] in
someone's front yard like just crazy
like jaywalk like the gun for everything
and DC goes like this because they just
shot The Flash and DC goes like this
uh
well let's uh let's see uh let's play
let's play it out
they wait a few months
they do reshoots with him so they're
like well they're Dublin done okay and
people like they're really should drop
the trailer in the Super Bowl
now people are like hell yeah I can't
wait you know all the people in like the
foreign places are like hell yeah I
can't wait for this movie and then
there's the the woke people in America
that are like what what they I will not
support the you know and it's like okay
but then I go like whoa dude they're
just gonna put this out there and that's
hundreds of other people worked on this
movie let the movie come out you know
how I feel obviously about it because
also
I got cut out of some [__] and it was a
Zack Snyder thing and Zack Snyder runs
DC and he's they're just letting this
Ezra Miller thing come out dude was
arrested and I'm just like oh really
it's about money dude
us about money though
so anytime you know I hear I see you
know this was years ago Zack Snyder in
an interview oh yeah well for the
humanity the right thing to do is recast
the thing oh what's up
dude
and I don't know what's true or what's
not true with this with this guy Ezra
but it's like
oh so you don't actually care it's all
about the so it's like huh
so it's not about it's just not really
about Humanity it's about oh ha
okay
all good
just so as we know right
just so as we know it's like you know
capitalism always wins dude you don't
have to like dude you don't have to come
out it's so crazy when people because
some people get cut out a movie some
people don't it depends at all you know
people got recast and we got recasting
something recently because there's
something somebody come out saying
something about I can't remember what
the [__] it was but it was like
that
the whole thing with cancer culture it's
like people only get mad when they think
that they can do something and and they
can change it
if they don't then they won't or they
might but it's on deaf ears and whatever
that's all I'll say about that but it's
just [__] crazy dude people are like
yeah dude people are just like so mad at
Ezra which I don't know it's I don't
know if it's true or not I have no
[__] idea but then it's like
The Flash though and then oh but then
Michael Keaton still Batman okay well
[__] it dude because you know what I
mean and this is why because because DC
but also Warner Brothers but you know
what I mean but like yeah and we know it
was there was a bunch of accusations and
he kidnapped someone but but uh you know
what I mean so go [__] yourself all he
is yes and no all he is
I don't [__] care anymore
so it's like
I want to do you know what these [__]
I swear to God the chat GPD things it is
taking it over bro I think technology
has just started We're not gonna need
actors We're not gonna need We're not
gonna need actors we're not going to
need actors I guess if you give
someone's like this like you Tom Hanks
will it by the time Tom Hanks dies
we won't need him anymore you understand
he's not he's not gonna die in the next
you know 10 years but like by the time
he dies we won't need him anymore we can
still have Tom Hanks in movies and the
tomax will still be in movies because
they will just still make Tom Hanks in a
movie with AI and chat GPT and all this
[__] and you could do like [__]
Philadelphia too
or like Philadelphia beyond the grave
whatever the [__] you want to call it
but it's like
you can do what do you call it uh uh uh
uh Bridge of spies part two was he in
that
was he in that Paul Rudd's in that too
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
actors are done novelists done chat GPT
is already killing it you see log lines
at our rights go put a chat chibi T and
say uh write me a Tom Cruise uh log line
for the new Mission Impossible movie
boom that's it guess what it'll be at
least just as good as a log line to
another
um that already exists
so we're [__] dude job wise
people who graphic designers
drivers of cars
[__] captains of boats and [__]
doctors
we're [__] 12 years away of somebody
releasing a bunch of [__] work ants
inside a chest and and and not only they
don't [__] replacing a heart rebuilding
a bad one doc see oh but we need the
doctor to inject it yeah for a little
bit until we make the things smart
enough to just be the room where it the
whole robot is the room and then that's
and the injections and then it pumps the
little army ants into the thing and they
were you don't need this [__]
you don't need a doctor done
the only profession that will be
necessary
is stand-up comedian
[Music]
and why be because humor is very
intricate and subtle and yeah you could
make a robot that does jokes I get it
the chat GPD that that we do sometimes
on this podcast it's like okay
um when I talk about it in my way it
does sound kind of stupid and I do think
about like well what the [__] that is
basically what I said in this podcast
but you need that [__] dude you need me
we'll see we'll see by the time we'll
see though dude I can't wait till the
first stand-up comedian chat GPT AI guy
comes out I can't wait to see it I can't
wait to see how bad it is you know it'll
be it'll be better than a Ben Stiller
movie a hundred percent
but I don't mean to [__] you know
smash on Ben Stiller I do hear he's a
[__] but I don't mean to smash on
him but I'm just saying
let's do a chat gbt joke right now
this is a Tom Cruise one you just did it
Tom Cruise and what just Tom Cruise you
just put Tom Cruise in it as a joke is
this a joke thing for me
write a joke about Tom Cruise oh so Ivan
gets rid of Rodin write a joke about Tom
Cruise in the style of crystallia that's
what he wrote and here it is you know
it's crazy now I did not write this chat
GPD wrote this now this is what I'm
gonna do read it and I'm gonna try to I
have not read this yet I'm going to try
to do it as much like me as I possibly
can first read you know what's crazy Tom
Cruise runs in every movie he's in like
what what is the deal with that it's
like what yeah you can't just walk or
take a taxi but no he's gotta run
everywhere he's like the Forest Gump of
action movies I mean have you seen the
Mission Impossible movies that guy is
sprinting all over the place it's like
calm down Tom this is not a marathon but
you know what maybe it is a marathon
maybe it is the Tom Cruise never-ending
running Challenge and the prize being in
more movies I guess I don't know man
guys got energy dude
what that I don't need to you know what
actually scratch that I don't need to do
this podcast anymore that I I am
actually going to do a whole podcast of
just chat GPT and it's going to be an
hour of that not now but in the future
this is unbelievable you know what this
chat GPT is doing for me
making me realize stuff about Tom Cruise
and Mission Impossible you know the only
thing I would rewrite is
Tom Cruise never-ending running
Challenge and the prize running in more
movies would be funnier than being in
more movies this is crazy it's like a
hamster wheel of the [__] wow now I'm
just being chat GPD basically how the
[__] do they know what I would do this
is insane
this is about artificial intelligence
jokes about what in my style of
crystallia or I haven't get rid of just
the artificial intelligence my style
Chrisley style of joking here we go
I did not write this
artificial intelligence huh
what a scam it's like every time I hear
about it I'm like where's the real
intelligence
I mean we've got robots that can play
chess and answer trivia questions but
they still can't fold laundry or make a
sandwich it's like come on AI step up
your game
but you know what maybe we're asking too
much maybe AI is just like us trying to
figure out life and find his purpose
maybe one day robots will run the world
and be like remember when we thought we
were just playing chess oh man how silly
we were but until then I'll just stick
to using it to play video games and have
conversation with random strangers
online that's the AI Revolution okay so
what that was what it was so this is
terrifying because also not only is it
getting me nail on the head this is
Crystal style humor it's also secretly
telling us what it's doing
AI through me
in my mind [__] this is [__] how does
it know
I guess it just took my stand up into a
database and or my podcast and now this
is what it's saying it's secretly
telling us what it's going to do AI
it's secretly telling us where's the
real intelligence
they can't make a fan that is true
though that is true actually why do the
robots not make sandwiches for us yet
why isn't it folding up we have to get
like a [__] a nanny why do we have to
get
a cleaning lady to fold our laundry
because they know the AI knows if they
were robots doing stuff in our houses
yet because there could be right but if
there were if they AI made this [__]
then what they could do
that seems threatening
here's another one about UFOs
humor and Socrates Leah all right here
we go
UFOs man what's the deal by the way I
wanna I want credit with how good I am
on these first reads okay
UFOs man what is the deal why does
everyone say what's the deal this is
like a [__] Seinfeld thing like that
this is just
the what
do I do yeah I do I say that I'm a hack
all right UFOs man what's the deal with
those things it's like every time I hear
about a sighting I'm like really aliens
I mean I want to believe I really do but
it's so hard with all the fake videos
and the photos out there it's like who
do we believe the government the
conspiracy theorists the people who
claim they've been abducted it's like
who do we trust but you know what maybe
that's the point
maybe the aliens are just messing with
us playing a cosmic game of cat and
mouse and maybe one day they'll land
their ships on the White House lawn and
be like
surprise we've been watching it this
whole time and we'll be like oh my God
and then the probably
try to enslave us or something but hey
at least we'll finally have proof of
extraterrestrial life so you know
there's that I added you know but I was
that I okay let's this is
making me feel bad about my comedy
honestly and I know I said that already
before that but this is unbelievable
that
oh
wait you know what we should do is do a
do a Bill Burr one do it in the style of
Bill Burr and I'll do it I'll do it like
Bill Burr
um chat GPT uh I don't know what would
pick something what
Tom Cruise for Bill Barrow okay cool
sounds good this is Tom Cruise with the
humor of Bill Burr
uh and then put it on here and then
we'll see what's going on here
this is absolutely insane to me that
chat GPT can do this
but how about the thing that what was
the thing called the the Seinfeld thing
that they made the loop and then it got
canceled what was it called Nothing
forever you heard about this nothing for
everything on Twitch it was basically a
uh a
um AI of Seinfeld episodes that would
just feed off each other and then it
would keep adding to itself and it was
going on and on on Twitch and it was
like it was just basically this chat gbt
thing and then all of a sudden it made a
trans joke and then it got canceled a
robot got canceled AI got canceled it
didn't even know what it was doing it's
not even AI yet really it's just uh like
an algorithm talk about and then they go
oh we gotta cancel a robot has been
canceled
you understand
here we go here we go this is this is
Bill Burr Tom Cruise
in the chat GPT in the humor style of
Bill Burr here we go Tom Cruise what's
up with this guy I mean he's got more
energy than a five-year-old on the sugar
high he it's like does he ever stop does
he ever take a break does he ever sit
down and watch a movie or read a book or
something no he's always running and
jumping and fighting it's like come on
man slow down
you're making the rest of us look bad
but you know what maybe that's the
secret to his success maybe he's got
some kind of superhero ability maybe
he's got some kind of alien blood or
something I don't know man all I know is
I can't keep up with this guy he's like
a human Energizer Bunny he just keeps
going and going and going well imagine
that's what he did on paper tiger people
would just be like um
maybe that means he's a good comedian
because his isn't funny and mine is
[__] AI [__]
they are yeah they are they're very
similar there's no difference if I just
did that in my voice it would be
wow this is unbelievable okay well look
we're all [__]
I don't know what to do anymore
um
is what it is
is what it is you know I just think it's
crazy that uh
you know what's everything's kind of
becoming the same like I I look at this
uh Super Bowl I know I talked about it
already the Super Bowl but like when I
look at Super Bowl and the
people who were there like the the the
celebs at the game it's like such a
celebrity thing it makes me not want to
go you know there's you know there's
that whole thing where like look social
media is absolutely awful for us and we
know that and I wouldn't be on it if I
wasn't a comedian but
um
it's like
the the you compare yourself to these
people online that obviously it's not
even how they live life like you know
you go to somebody's Instagram Kyle
Kardashian Kylie whatever Kyrie what's
her name
Kyrie Irving Kardashian and um
and you see all the the moments where
her of her big butt and like with Tyga
or whatever she's dating what the [__]
a guy's name Travis Scott
and uh Kyrie Irving Kardashian is dating
tiger Scott and so
basically you see her in a limo you see
her wait you know what's thinking who
the [__] it's limos anymore
there's no limos anymore right
I was talking about this with one of my
buddies they're just done
you just get Uber Escalades if you want
to be balling right
I gotta bring the limo back dude
didn't that long stretchy thing right
the only I was talking about this let's
talk about this was I talk about this at
Golden hour I don't know the only person
who gets limos is if you arrive in Vegas
and they want to treat you nice
right what dork rolls up in a limo now
it's way cooler to arrive in for Real uh
Hyundai Elantra and an Uber guys driving
and I don't sit in the front seat I sit
in the back I don't care I don't care
my buddy Brent Morin's got that joke
where it looks like two friends and one
and then they got in a fight
but I don't I I go in the back dude I'm
not sitting in the front of your Uber
and here's why because I don't want to
have this moment
I I don't you can't see me I'm the back
I'm in the back you can't see me I only
want you if I'm in your car and I've
never met you I only want you to be able
to see me if you're using a mirror
that's it
oh yeah that's the combo okay well
that's cool that's it
so uh
uh social media is toxic couldn't think
of the word social media great
um social media is toxic
you know you look at just take me people
think I'm a raging [__] because of
the stuff I talk about on my podcast I'm
activated I'm online I'm on the I'm you
know I post a real of me bitching about
the food in my rehab or you know talking
about [__] about Rihanna whatever it
is you know making a joke being silly
but you know I I get it I'm biting and
[__] and people just think I'm an
[__]
this is a 60 second clip online that I'm
posting or you know
however long it is
and people go [__] this guy they don't
know
that after that after I do my podcast I
go I cuddle with my child I kiss my wife
we watch something really nice on TV
Like A Bug's Life we watched it the
other day by the way Bug's Life does not
hold up okay
they don't even know this was Pixar it
was 1998 it came out they didn't even
know that they had to make the
characters look different they all look
the same it's really really it's
depressing my son was having a blast
watching it and I couldn't turn it off
even though it was kind of depressing it
doesn't hold up but my son was just like
loving it anyway I digress but what I'm
saying is you don't get to see those
tender moments you don't get to see the
real person moments you just see what I
put on Instagram or whatever it is Tick
Tock me yelling about a [__] dry
cleaning service or whatever happened
and I seem activated and so you think
that guy's a [__] or you think that
guy's got it made because I took a
picture in my [__] car with the
bloody guts oops
and yeah I stack Gaper but do you know
what's going on in my metal but that's
fine I don't mean to make this about me
but my point is
what the [__] did Rihanna do after that
halftime show
she looks like she's got it man
she killed it she's [__] four and a
half five months pregnant whatever it is
she killed it what she do afterwards she
probably went into the bathroom and
[__] threw up because she's too
pregnant or whatever it is dude people
go through what they go through my point
is Kyrie Kardashian
and uh tiger Scott
they got their [__] going on
and it's toxic because you have a
representation of who they are and then
not only that you see the good moments
of their lives and then you think your
life sucks because you don't have those
good moments of those like in the
meantime you're posting your cool
pictures
in wherever the hell you are with nice
filters and looking cool you got your
new Fendi bag and you're showing it off
at the Grand Canyon
but you're crying over a breakup and
you're not doing it there the picture
so my point is
yeah it's very toxic
I don't even know what [__] point I
was trying to make there
but oh
you see these celebs at the Super Bowl
and they're having a good time you look
at Diplo you look at you know whoever
look I got a whole thing here of the
people
all the celebs at the you know Jay-Z's
there you know you had uh Gordon Ramsay
on the field
being a dick to people or whatever it is
you got Quest love
with uh Adam Blackstone I don't know who
it is cara de Levine cara de Levine with
the Rihanna shirt cool
Jordan Sparks which
yeah uh you know
look at these different people uh
Bradley Cooper you know it's I don't
know everyone it's like and then you
look and you like and I know you
secretly think like ah [__] I want to be
there
I get it
and you know me I don't want to be there
anyway because it's got a bunch of
anytime a bunch of people are somewhere
I kind of don't want to be there unless
they're all staring at me and it's my
show see good testicle but all good but
the point is
um Tracy Morgan look at that in with the
booth in the front of the thing he's
Rich As [__] huh because he got hit by a
thing
Walmart truck
but how rich do you have to be for real
to just be on the field
and not be like Gordon Ramsay just
straight up
they go they go how much for tickets and
they go they say ah it's like uh you
know
seventy thousand dollars for a bad seat
and he's like uh what about I feel like
I'm gonna be on a field
and they're like it's actually priceless
and he says I'll have that much
Elon Musk on the field right here he is
on a field
the people on the field
just priceless
I have that much
who are some of these people
actor Paul Walter Hauser who's that
this is where I'm going I'm scrolling
pretty far so
oh Twitter founder yeah why yeah well
he's got some money huh
Jay-Z okay baby face
oh Tiffany I just love her dude um so
it's like I don't I don't want to be
there you catch me at a star-studded
event just know if you see a picture of
me there
and I'm I'm I try to be a positive
person
I'm hey
I'll smile
catch me behind my face though dude I'm
hating it dude
I do not want to do it
I don't want to be there and the whole
goal is to get there and be a part of
the show but
it's not fun dude
man
it's really not fun
you get caught up in it in Hollywood you
get caught up in it
like I was like yeah I want to do movies
and I want to do another movie and then
this movie will help me do another thing
you get bigger I don't want to I don't
want to get bigger I just want to have
my fans I want to rock with you
[__] I want to talk on this
podcast I want to be with my family
that's it dude
do I want to go to the soft opening of
some no
yeah but nah you know who's gonna be
there who this new up-and-coming rapper
and a guy who cooks food on TV nah I'm
good
yeah but it might help you I don't
that's okay
gq's gonna be there and so it doesn't
matter
is Calvin gonna be there no I'm good my
wife she gonna be there
still want to go I'm good she could go
to bed at 9 30 p.m because she's
pregnant and I'll just watch bad movie
I'll just watch you know what I'll watch
I'll watch the last 10 movies Bruce
Willis made that's what I'll watch
the movies that they forced him to be in
he didn't even know where he was that's
the movies I'll watch Gasoline Alley or
something it's called right it'll be him
and the guy from [__] um
what's that movie uh Final Destination
that's what it's called Gasoline Alley
you think I'm wrong I'm not
uh Bruce Willis and the guy from Final
Destination in a movie called Gasoline
Alley that's the movie I'll watch when
my wife goes to bed early
rather than hang out with [__] baby
face and uh Dr Drew who by the way I
love Dr Drew and I'm sure Babyface is a
nice guy time to change your name though
huh
like I mean I'm in dude I mean no I'm in
home
because I was at one time I was out in a
vet at an event I can't remember what
the hell it was but it was like you
should go and I was like all right I'll
go
and then uh I you know I used to follow
this
she's a good actress I think she's good
man Nikki Whalen I think she's a [__]
good actress and I was like oh she's
[__] cool and you know this is years
ago she would say oh you're so funny I'm
like oh yeah that's [__] cool
whatever she had a boyfriend you know I
tried to hang out with her like [__]
nine years ago
and then uh and then she was like uh
she always would write like haha or
something I was like she's not
interested or whatever it was all good
and then uh I saw her at an event and I
was like ah [__] hey what's up how
you doing and I go to like give her a
hug and she goes okay and she was so
weird about it and I was like ah [__]
all right okay
we're not people I'm done then
I'm done then I'm out I'm out I'm not
coming to these [__] GQ parties and
[__] you gotta stand next to a [__]
sweaty guy that was like
that's in [__] What's that show
Modern Family
and uh
and Josh Peck and by the way I love Josh
Peck but it's like what am I doing here
I went to one and I was with Aaron Paul
all night and then I got pink eye the
next day I'm texting Aaron Paul do you
have pink eye no
like what is Hollywood
so weird it's such a rat race
once you get unhooked from The Matrix
once you get unhooked and you realize oh
I'm just a guy who [__] speaks to my
fans I'm by the way I love you
[__] and I don't even like the
word fans I get it I know you are but
also your people and this is why I say
it's a cult dude we got to get in that
tall grass and build that [__]
log cabin and
a guy with a podcast
that's what's up dude
G-Unit that's what's up can't say that
the do the n word in the middle but
so the calm down of the coffee is real
but I'm just saying
it's a rat race it's always about
getting the next one right everything in
life is always about getting the next
one it's so hard to be so happy and
centered and happy with what you already
have
it seems like people with long beards
are happier but it's like because you
just kind of gave up and you're like
this is my beard though what am I gonna
do do guys with beards get invited
can I go like this you know
ah
like And subscribe to the channel by the
way we love it we love it and leave a
comment for the algorithm you know I
don't know if this is a patreon episode
or not but
if it's not leave leave a comment for
the algorithm you know and share with
your friends dude
how the [__] are we supposed to grow
this
I heard that Jerry oh wait no not Jared
Leto who's the guy that
is it Jared no Jared Leto had a cult and
he invited people to his cult but there
was another guy recently that had a cult
that was like Ayah uh what was it
I don't know what it was
I can't remember some some guy had a was
trying to have a cult
and uh he invited people no who is it
Jared Leto no it was somebody else
I don't know whatever what
yeah celebrity
who cares
I need to have a movie I need to have my
own um Hollywood
that's why I say I want to get into
Bollywood
let's take a break for a second here I
gotta go to the bathroom
now let's do some [__] misconnections
and these are only back because MGK
asked me to put him back
so you could thank him for that go on
his Instagram and say thanks for
kristalia bringing back misconnections
this one's called oozing out gross
already but let's see if it gets grosser
my guess is it will
I have pipes that need to be cleaned
two weeks of build up are ready to come
oozing out
assistance please not
a sit like I need assistance from you
like assistance like I need a few people
to come help
assist me with that and I don't know if
he meant to write assistance like I need
some assistance but I like it way better
if he's like please only apply if you're
an assistant if you're if you're up to
being an assistant
do not contact me with unsolicited
services or offers that's amazing great
here's another one anyone looking for
dot dot dot and in the body of
of the [__] post
it says
head
with a question mark first of all I love
it when the title has more words than
the body
it's so disrespectful and lazy
anyone he didn't write anyone dot dot
dot and then the body looking for head
he wrote anyone looking for dot dot dot
oh what's this guy looking for you check
the body head and you go whoa actually
yes
because it was not
do not contact me on solicited Services
officers that means that you better just
be looking for ahead if that's what
you're
that's great dude I love how it's not kg
at all how come some of these people are
like man need a plumber to come by to
see what's going on my pipes there might
be some kind of thing maybe some
guys who work at the on a boat like some
semen can come like and it's like so
like oh what is he talking about but we
know what he's talking about
but then some guy's just like hey
honestly
come from the dot dot dot
s all right bleep that out we're gonna
get demonetized but
here's another one you look you looked
good to me and this is the the Poetry
this is a poem I guess I don't know
maybe it's written in the Haiku form not
Haiku because it's way longer about
poetry form this is what it says after
that you looked good to me even with
your insecurities
written by a Japanese guy that has known
English for four years so look it's
called you look good to me and it this
is the first time you looked good to me
even with your insecurities then another
line you looked good to me then another
line you looked good to me
oh that guy's such a [__] first year
poet writer dude you look good to me
with your insecurities you look good to
me you looked good to me dude you know
what it is it's like the [__] uh So I
Married an Ax Murderer
you look good to me even with your
insecurities
so you look at me that you look at me
you looked good to me you looked good to
me if you'd taken time to see if you'd
taken the time to ask
you were so busy looking at this is a
[__] Bryan Adams song you were so
busy if you're taking the time to see if
you're taking the time to ask
you were so busy looking at them
titties no I don't know what he's gonna
say but you were so busy looking at them
while I was right there looking at you
well this is Brian Adamson
this was the this is basically the song
from Robin Hood with [__] Kevin
Costner while I was right there looking
at you you looked good to me if you'd
taken the time to see again you looked
good to me even with your insecurities
I'm sorry I was never good enough for
you to see me
so
[__]
atrocious this is the worst poem I've
ever heard in my life this is a Brian at
what
what is the [__]
what's the [__] chemical we gotta
play a little bit of it maybe we can't
play it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah everything I do oh I'm gonna
do it for you
but I die boy dude when I heard that
song as a little kid I go like this oh
there will not be a song better than
this one dude when I was nine and I
heard that song a nine-year-old hearing
Bryan Adams just screaming that [__]
[__] out on a rock to the ocean I go as
a nine-year-old I go like this oh well
that's actually really sad because
I'll never hear another song better than
this in my nine-year-old brain that's
what I thought dude and then honestly
Life as a highway came along and I go oh
never mind and that's the second podcast
in a row I have mentioned life in the
life is a highway so you're welcome and
also know the podcast will do that and
we talk about the hard-hitting issues
and you know it's like what do you what
else do you want for me so here's
another one
PornHub actress needed
Santa Barbara by living in Santa Barbara
and doing poor you must be rolling in it
you don't need anything she's like you'd
have all your [__] together here we go
Hello exclamation point looking for a
female modeling partner or S partner or
Partners if this speaks your interest
please feel free to respond must be
clean with recent proof and a face
picture it's a great opportunity and
foot in the door to be noticed in the
adult industry series serious inquiries
only please thank you hope you have a
good day and hope to hear from you
looking as long as this is up dude this
is the thing about
like
this is the Shady you're gonna get
murdered if you do this
you're going to get straight up murdered
this is a murderer doing this it's this
is one of those posts where you look and
I actually read Because I read a lot of
these and I go oh you know what this
actually seems legit the second you
think something seems legit on [__]
Craigslist you signed your death
certificate you're dead the most
shittiest thing I ever did on Craigslist
is I went to go pick up an Xbox when it
first came out the first Xbox ever I got
it in an Alleyway I handed the guy
[__] hundred dollar bills and I went
home I played Call of Duty for nine
years and I will tell you dude it was
the shittiest thing I did I went with
another guy if I didn't go with another
guy there would be no crystalia
foreign but I went with another guy
that Xbox never got that red ring of
death it was always working so anyway
dude thank you very much that's the
episode for this evening or this morning
or whatever it is dude
uh Kansas City Minneapolis Austin Texas
I will be there chrisley.com oh well
that's the episode uh for YouTube if you
want to catch the rest of the episode
The uncut episode the uh on with no ads
no nothing just a raw unedited thing
just go to patreon.com crystallia and
you'll get every episode and it's
entirely with nothing cut no ads and you
will also get all of the backlog
episodes of congratulations there's like
22 23 now it's worth it and it's only
six bucks patreon.com crystalia thanks
foreign
[Music]